here is your white wine Hey you are
welcome
hey Pete little uh little thirsty
tonight ah yeah super thirsty beep this
is a race' erase' this is not pete
harissa just got back from Africa Oh
Africa anyways uh where was I
oh the aec oh right so this conflict is
exactly the reason the African Union
Commission was put in place to address
the organization of African Unity
certainly wasn't going to do it exactly
and if an coast is honored limini Zuma
wants to do anything about Bangui she's
certainly been quiet about it the worst
part about funky is that no one knows
what's going on we look at right next
door the South Sudan here's the thing
everybody just thinks that it's like
it's the damn Lion King over there you
know Lion King excuse me
it's not the Lion King
exactly I mean what do people think a
baboon is gonna hold a lion cub over a
rock up to the Sun while all the little
animals sing anyway something else I
wanted to mention is they have the
manpower because AMISOM has 25,000
troops just sitting there in Somalia
it's not a three animated hyena
situation that doesn't make any sense
the bad guy isn't scar over there yeah
yeah that's right it's not like scars
the bad guy well I mean you know the
truth is no one knows who to blame
because in reality Amazon doesn't have
that much control I don't like Simba Oh
like Simba he had no control over well
he was plucked out from his home and
went on a whole journey before he came
back and was just in the middle of a war
really had nothing to do with him you
know Pete I'd be really interested in
hearing your thoughts on the UN's
policies in East Africa
hakuna matata unbelievable
yes
that sums it up perfectly there's so
much work still to be done
that's what I was saying it's not going
on for so many years so many years
circle of life hmm
exactly that's really brilliant ever
been brilliant let's dial it back I'm
just a man okay uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
go get some mmm some hors d'oeuvres okay
no need to announce it
what are your thoughts on the Middle
East the Latin
you